I had expectations from other people in
my mind who were constantly judging the
behaviors and actions I was doing every
day and were telling me that I was not
enough I came up with a mantra [__]
happiness in choosing not to admit the
deficiency between my current state and
the future state of what I desire to be
I was able to accept where I was and
then the deficiency of not being good
enough not being happy enough
disintegrated in my mind and then I was
able to focus on just doing things and
then when I started doing things I
started making progress when I started
making progress I started looking back
and feeling proud of how far I had come
because it wasn't about the many voices
outside it was about the only one that
mattered